We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a question about an interesting scenario
that could present itself.
If Donald Trump loses in November.
Take a listen.
Hey, David.
Question as far as likability on this one,
but what are the chances that.
If Trump loses in this election, that's Joe
Biden.
They are four years, five, four years.
Whoever else, is there a chance?
Do you think that Donald Trump tries to run
it?
Yeah, I'm just a hard no on this.
I believe that if Donald Trump loses in November,
that's it.
In politics for him, Donald Trump will be
what he'd be 78, 78, 79, when he would assume
a presidential term in January of 2025.
I just don't see it.
And Trump said if he loses, he's going to
go and work on something else.
So I don't believe we're going to see that
whatsoever.
I think you're not going to see Trump go peacefully
if he loses in November.
But we've already talked about that.
But I. Trump.
Donald Trump.
2024.
I don't see what one of his kids may try to
do.
Then that's that remains an open question
on the bonus show today.
We will talk about our respective little vacations
that we had last week.
We are going to talk about the House passing
a bill for Washington, D.C. statehood.
Very, very interesting and much to discuss.
We will also talk about Sacha Baron Cohen
crashing a right wing event.
And it has led to so much chaos once again.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member or a patron.
Membership is join Pacman dot com patrie on
is Patrick ENCOM slash David Pakman show.
I'll see you then.